das ist passé
das trifft man die anderen
ich dachte immer dass das kann mir gar
nicht passieren nur wenn ich davor
gehörte dachte ich
dann bin ich nicht ich dachte dafür
müsse man die unachtsam sein wird
das habe ich auch nicht wollte
nicht
spaß beiseite und ernst an die seite
ernst j
heute ist hat sich über uns das
passieren was man jetzt auch von anderen
youtuber hören die ich nicht darüber
beschweren twitter in videos weil es so
ein ganz großes youtuber problem und ich
dachte mir irgendwie so dass wir das
nicht wirklich passieren kann aber heute
ist es leider passiert ihr seht schon im
titel verstanden zu shop vor der tür
so jetzt erst mal die ganze
rahmengeschichte ich bin jetzt ja gerade
nicht da wo ich studiert das erkennt
vielleicht auf dem sofa das so versteht
nämlich da wo max und meine familie
wohnen ganze geschichte war so ich bin
halt heute einfach von seinem studienort
wieder vier stunden 51 heute sogar auf
der autobahn staubach alle autobahn
fahre auf jeden fall kam ich dann nach
fünfeinhalb stunden party total genervt
an mein auto ist jetzt nicht das
komfortabelste deswegen sind fünfeinhalb
stunden autobahnfahrten echt schon
schlauch kommen wir annehmen meine
koffer aus dem auto ich bin so genervt
im moment wirklich so richtig richtig
abgefragt die in die kirche um etwa ein
glas wasser pipapo meine kleine
schwester auf einmal gucken wer ist das
denn
und ich gehe zum küchenfenster und aus
dem küchenfenster müsst ihr wissen kann
auf die straße aus schauen weil ich
schon raus und sie so drei mädels so
relativ jung soo zwischen 9 13 14 würde
ich sagen okay wahrscheinlich dass green
freundin von freundin schwester aber so
kommt mir nichts dabei gedacht dann sage
ich zu herrn konnte dass das eine freude
von dir
wieso ich kann die nicht und ich konnte
es gar nicht eingreifen ich wusste gar
nicht was ich sagen weil ich es hat
alles gegangen sind erklärt ich war so
mental mitgenommen von dieser
autobahnfahrt dass ich mir gar nichts
dabei gedacht leute meine kleine
schwester aber bisschen stimmt zuschauer
nicht so ja klar selbstverständlich ins
zuschauer was sonst bin ich rausgegangen
wenn zu tür gegangen wo irgendwie hat
mir wohl schon bemerkt dass ich von der
küche zum hauseingang gegangen war um
rauszugehen und syrien zu stellen wenn
er aber bin ich rausgegangen und zu zwei
sekunden später waren alle weg wo die
hatten dann schon so zehn meter gemacht
man wahrscheinlich gerannt oder so ich
bin natürlich hinterher auf socken sogar
nur
gesagt die leute bei mal kurz stehen wo
ich ein komisches gefühl so mit diesen
mädels zu müssen wir die mir auch immer
den vor leid getan hat zumindest zwei
von denen man hat so richtig gemerkt
zwei waren so einfach normale
verständliche menschen verstehen was ich
meine leute wieder so eine gewisse
menschlichkeit in sich drin haben die
hat ja heutzutage nicht jeder aber
zweifel waren echt normalen als ich
ihnen gesagt habe worum es ging weil ich
gesagt dass ich euch gleich an die auch
wirklich gezeigt dass es ihnen peinlich
war dass ihr das nicht so wollen aber
die dritte ständiger zeit also dass man
über die älteste das war die fucking
älteste von diesen drei die stand aber
die ganze zeit gelacht ich so mega pisst
mega aggressiver kurz zuvor aus zu
lassen
und die steht da und lacht sich darauf
so zackig er dürfte den tag wird kommen
wo ich meinem urteil fähigkeiten
einsetzen aber so gegen 39 12
vielleicht ist das nicht so der richtige
zeitpunkt ich hab den hinterhergerufen
laufsocken raus dazu den gesagt japan
stehen
such dir irgendwas und die darin sich so
um und da kommt nicht so was wie ja
sorry
dann kam wirklich helfen wird und dann
nachdem sie dreimal um mein gott oder es
stimmt wirklich er wohl wirklich da
gesagt haben wir irgendwann angefangen
menschlich miteinander zu kommunizieren
ich habe ihnen gesagt sucht irgendwas
wieder mehr zuschauer da was in dem
moment schon ziemlich offensichtlich war
auch allein aufgrund dieser reaktionen
dieses open gut ich meine irgendwie
rentnerin die auf der straße treffe sagt
ja nicht oh mein gott zu mir ich hätte
sich youtube minecraft webspace ja und
dann habe ich die mädels zur rede
gestellt habe sie gefragt was das leute
hab ihm gesagt erstmals über die ganze
straße geschrien so mehr oder weniger
weil ihr mann hatten bestanden dass das
überhaupt nicht in ordnung ist bindend
hinterhergerannt oder durch wird hierzu
gehören damit wir uns besser bestehen
akustisch sagt was soll das wird warum
seid ihr hier die soja und irgendjemand
darunter erzählt dass karl crafter
darunter wohnt die haben sich da scheint
irgend jemand hat mir erzählt dass der
unter in kuba dar und die ist
wahrscheinlich auch nur deswegen wissen
weil sie mit maximal auf eine schule
gegangen sind und ihn dann verfolgt
haben nach hause bei anders erfährt dass
keiner mal ist jeder kann übrigens bei
youtube
nein es war so dass irgendwelche leute
die mit max auf einer schule waren quasi
nach der schule abgepasst haben und iso
nach hause verfolgt haben mehr oder
weniger an der cover scheinbar und das
max gemerkt hatten deswegen wussten max
wohnen damit wo auch ich wohne und dann
haben diese jungs das dann scheinbar
irgendwelchen leuten weiter erzählt so
mach war ja auch einfach mal so ja
allein der gedanke habe mich immer total
genervt dass irgendwer draußen ist und
rum erzählt wo man selbst wohl was
eigentlich kein staatsgeheimnis ist aber
andererseits auch die leute haben es
halt nur dadurch erfahren dass die
maxime die verfolgten nach hause so
damals selbst erzählte okay aber die
wissen es ja wirklich nur daher dann
geben sie folgend ich anderen leuten
damit an dass sie wissen wo wir wohnen
und dann erzählt sich diesen leuten auch
noch weiter und die anderen leute dies
nur von anderen gehört und was wir da
wohl doch eher über uns vorbei und
schauen mal kurz das klingelschild ja da
könnte ich echt schon seit links zeit
rechtzeitig von tool fraser upper cut
geben die gesagt in dieser situation
einerseits die mädels leid getan
andererseits macht mir auch so es kann
irgendwo nicht sein irgendwo vielleicht
ist auch echt doof
gerade wenn meine kleine schwester meine
rechts die familie in dem haus noch wohl
vor allem eine kleine schwester da
kriegt also fortan beschützerinstinkt
rein wenn ich jetzt irgendwo planung
fucking timbuktu wohnen würde und dem
buchdruck linien an meiner haustür oder
schon das klingelschild wenn er nur ich
wurde mit dem andere youtuber zusammen
dann ist das nervig aber in die familie
mit noch jüngeren familienmitglieder in
dem haus wohnt ist nervig sondern dann
ist es gleich eine ganz andere heikle
sache die geschichte ging an so weiter
dass die dann versucht irgendwie so zu
gehen und ich das natürlich nicht
zugelassen habe also nicht im sind jetzt
die aufgehalten hat körperlich aber ich
habe ein bisschen geredet hat gesagt
dass das überhaupt nicht in ordnung geht
und wie gesagt zwei von denen man
verständnis gezeigt man sieht es den
menschen die auch an wenn er ihr
verständnis für irgendwas zeigt wenn er
sich wegen irgendwas nicht so gut fühlt
das sieht man an der körpersprache diese
ein bisschen zurückhaltender sieht man
an der mimik das sieht man daran den
mensch redet und zwei von denen die bei
den jüngeren waren wirklich sehr
verständlich und für die tools mir fast
ein bisschen leid aber die ältere von
diesem 3 die war echt irgendwie als sie
war schwer geistig behindert hab ich's
gefühl und das ist eigentlich eine
berechtigung gegenüber schwerbehinderten
menschen weil die irgendwie so
vollkommen aus dem leben gekriegt war
die hat irgendwie überhaupt nicht
verstanden worum es geht in diesen
momenten dass es darum geht dass ich
mich damit unwohl fühle dass ich als
freundin sich auch mit der situation um
gefühle und dass man so was eigentlich
nicht macht die stadt
es war die älteste von drei diäten
nichts gescheit die geht so am leben
vorher aber andererseits ich will jetzt
auch nicht jeder zweite youtuber
irgendwie sind video drüber machen nur
scheiße leute ist es einfach total
schlecht seit die schlimmsten unter
menschen dafür dass ihr euch dafür
interessiert eure lieblings youtuber
wohnen leute ich kann es nachvollziehen
dass man das gerne wissen möchte und
dass es irgend interessant ist aber es
ist echt ein komisches gefühl wenn man
da ist man selbst wohnt wenn man da ist
wo die eigene familie wohnt wo auch wie
gesagt auch familienmitglieder wohnt ist
ein wichtiger faktor in dem moment weil
die besonders schutzbedürftig sind und
dann kommen einfach irgendwelche leute
an die einen von youtube kennt und
spazieren darum und vor jesus niki wie
laufen dahin in diese sehr ruhige
abgeschiedene straße stellen sich vor
unser haus und guck mal vom ostring ich
bin einfach dafür dass wir einfach
menschlich miteinander umgehen ich bin
mensch ihr zuschauer seit menschen und
wie wäre es wenn wir einfach gegenseitig
unsere bedürfnisse respektieren denkt
das sinnvoll ist dass man einfach ein
deal abschließt dass der youtuber nicht
alle zwei wochen auf twitter postet
formalen diese fans diese wann sollte
ich denn schon wieder bei mir vor der
tür und dass die zuschauer sich denken
in seiner privatsphäre sondern dass
zuschauer und youtube sich gegenseitig
als menschen respektieren und sagen okay
dann gegenüber bedürfnis hat der
youtuber sagt ich kann verstehen dass
manche zuschauer sich dafür
interessieren wo ich wohne und ich
respektiere ist auch irgendwo und
verurteilt die nicht dafür und stellt
sich wie schlechte menschen nur weil
sich dafür interessieren das interesse
ist ganz normal
was nicht in ordnung ist ist dann eben
darum zu kraxeln vor der haustür zu
stehen und der zuschauer auf der anderen
seite sollte sagen okay ich respektiere
den youtuber der youtuber ist ein mensch
das ist keine figur aus plastik dies nur
auf youtube gibt es ist ein mensch wie
ich der hat empfindung wie ich der hat
dinge die ihn stören
genauso wie ich und der hand welche
besonderen wünsche und in welche
bereiche in denen er seine ruhe haben
möchte ganz wie jeder andere mensch und
dementsprechend seine zuschauer sagen ok
ist adressiert mich zwar aber ich sehe
jetzt davon ab darum zu tanzen und schon
ist es ganz problem gelöst und niemand
wurde beleidigt niemand wurde fertig
gemacht niemand wurde zurecht gestutzt
ist einfach ein respektvoller umgang
miteinander der das ganze problem löst
das war so was heute passiert ist mit
ein bisschen klugscheißer reihe von mir
wenn euch die ganze geschichte sehr
investiert hat dann haften neigt dann
stelle ich mal vor ihr wählt ein youtube
gibt ihnen als geschwister und ihre
familie an dem ort und steht auf einmal
vor einfamilienhaus wohlgemerkt nicht
von irgendwo wo wir alle youtube sondern
vor allem familien haus wohl lange
gelebt hat und wo jüngere geschwister
wohnen aber einmal leute vor der tür wie
will die reagieren was würdet ihr machen
schaut das wollen die kommentare und bis
zum nächsten video haut rein was gut und
schickt